it's been rough right you know just
everybody's moving here now and it's
nuts but i love it
[Laughter]
juice
and what's the number from aaa
uh
[Music]
so this guy is young enough right here
where he's like who's rob snyder i was
like who knows which movie i said which
movie has anybody yeah god bless you
let me see
uh
juicer or no
it just collapsed
just a vehicle
vehicle system shutdown is this your
vehicle or is it a rental it's my wife's
of course
he's gonna contribute okay
but how do i copy this and paste it
you gotta hold it down yeah just hold
your thumb on the number on the number
there you go and then you gotta copy
that
yeah
that's where we are in the world i can't
remember 10 numbers
that happens
oh that's the uh triple a number yes
oh this is terrible thanks guys i
appreciate it we should get a little
treat to stand underneath these people
drive like loons
it was almost an accident right before
those guys came over
just
all all right thank you
okay i have a number for you
uh triple a roadside assistance
she gave me
[Music]
[Music]
no
i got the hell out of there
what's that i'm sorry i didn't
understand
you and bob sapp
will you beat the crap out of him
that is classic
do you remember that movie or the prison
yard
oh yeah
i was supposed to climb on his back in
that scene and the stunt guy said if he
falls on you the movie's over
is it really well the dude's like 370
pounds it was like exciting
he was eating all day long to keep that
muscle mass
you know as big as he is he lost a lot
of uh mma fights in japan just because
those guys over there
he's not a fighter really right he's a
huge dude
he wasn't even the best football player
when he played the nfl either it's not a
average
it's hard to do all that stuff he looked
great though
he didn't want to do the roll
and i said just do it i don't play a gay
guy he said no come on it's funny
he said all right i'll do
service
it
messages
uh
and my car broke down and it's blocking
the lane
i have three handsome police officers
helping me out
[Applause]
we are
we can't get a chance here
thank you
big bundle with big macs chicken nuggets
and we've got some one stop there
morgan's over at scottsdale
nice christmas shopping all the way
around
yep gotta take care of peach you live in
scottsdale now rob
well i had a place
and the contractor just
right and then now it's i've been an
airbnb for six months
so we just bought another place
i couldn't even tell you where it
okay
so we're up there
it's been rough right you know it's just
everybody's moving here now and it's
nuts but i love it here it's better
but it's uh we just we did a movie here
called daddy daughter trip we just
screened it uh
two nights ago it was fun
so we're trying to do stuff here
let's do stuff here not in june to
september right
sometimes still no better
sometimes still november really yeah
because there's been times where it's
been almost 100 degrees i've been up
until like
so
they're waiting on this
yeah we just finished the movie with
kevin james
oh that goes to the king of queens uh no
oh god dude
personal security detail
of course
no not even security actors oh yeah
you want to talk to there's an officer
right here
all right okay all right go ahead what
do i need what else you need here
nice
good one
nice i just gave it to you that's right
philippines all right
back i got sliced
where did it happen
i'm just kidding
what happened
uh i fell on the
slice
on a metal sign at carolyn resort when i
was chasing my kids
i should have gotten stitches
yes
i feel bad because i don't i don't know
where your uh i don't know where your
card in that starbucks card are right
now and they're floating somewhere in
there
they probably died of district one you
made someone's day
no it's not it's in b17 i said 94th and
topspeed so that's basically
topic
[Music]
probably should have just got probably
should just go
tesla
you up tomorrow
well hopefully they don't call me on
christmas okay i doubt they will because
people like christmas
it was weird because when we were trying
to figure out our payroll right no
because i was working overtime on friday
it screwed i couldn't get fto pay for
for tomorrow
because that's considered our holiday
okay
but i was already working holiday work
but then it came up with that extra time
they're slow they're slow as shit but
they're supposed to be doing it you know
we could call our toe and we'll cost you
a penny oh yeah
okay you want to try that
then i i don't know how long this is
going to be our guys will be here a lot
you know what might be my funniest movie
ever
grandma's boy oh yeah that was a fun one
that was hilarious they just show you
with like monkey would you dominate
those young kids at frogger
because that's that's like us that's old
school yeah about 54 so that was the
stuff we were playing in the 80s you
know it's like we're playing frogger and
tempest and
you know tron and defender and pac-man
miss pac-man you know they won't let you
make those kind of movies anymore it's
tough
that actors like this is not calculating
he looks like he should be in star wars
or something that movie's popular again
uh with college kids you know
yeah that would be great let's use
another these i don't know these people
aren't going to get here in an hour yeah
yeah i don't need to do a toshi because
it's not it's just a private joke
all right okay we got one we got one
rolling this way oh awesome okay i'll
just tell this lady
yeah they got a new series coming out on
paramount 1883. yeah i heard western i'm
probably going to start watching that
i've been watching everyone you know
we're both served in the military for a
lot of years
so i i was at recon in the marine corps
he's been uh he's been in the army um
but i i watch seal team on cbs and
paramount yeah it's
it's it's a pretty good series but
they've gotten they've gone to that
realm where they're dealing with like
their personal problems too much oh yeah
you know so for for the reality yeah
everybody has no problems with the
department of
curtail but
but the other one i like and i don't
know why i love narcos
oh yeah and then mexican artworks so
and then i watched with you and mcgregor
i watched the long way up from south
bottom of south america all the way up
to los angeles on those electric
motorcycles that they had you get
murdered doing that oh yeah it's like 13
000 miles wow it's a long ways
they were crossing passes in in the
argentinian andes that were over 16 000
feet on the roadway wow on an electric
motorcycle an electric motorcycle so
they have to charge it every day right
so the problem they ran into is ktm who
was supposed to be the original bike
company that made these and they said
hands up there we can't do this and
harley said we can do this so they spent
a year
24 hours a day for a solid year getting
these bikes ready these prototype bikes
and those rivion trucks that the newest
electric trucks on the market they've
been around since about 2013-14 they
produced a prototype truck to be able to
be their support truck so they basically
follow them and it shows how they there
were some places where they couldn't get
the electricity and the bikes would
break down it was so cold they couldn't
get in itself
that's it
[Applause]
okay no worries side of the road
all right rob we're going to take off
very nice meeting you though so much
nicer merry christmas
for coming all right yep all right all
right i appreciate it absolutely
yeah so thanks guys have a good
christmas thank you sir
you guys want to comment next week at
the uh
stand up live or the improv i'm going to
be one of those it's pretty fun i just
talked for an hour about um
stuff you want in tempe
yeah i think so yeah let me just check
and see where i'm supposed to be i'll
find it right
it could be stand up live i think it's
in tempe
yeah there's one right there i like
[Music]
yeah
let's stand up live
you guys want to take my number and if
you guys want to come out it's the 28th
29th
all right rob what is it
if you want to come i'll get you guys a
i'll get you guys a table
please tell jokes right now
they have to take you up
in the comedy club right you can't do on
tv yeah yeah it's stand-up live
it's pretty nice club
good to go all right good
thanks so much